bonjour marina torpilles bonjour bonjour
aux auditrices et auditeurs de
martinique la première et plus
particulièrement chez oiseaux chichewa
alors justement vous êtes la tête de
liste de l'équipe de campagne dénommée
réussir chaque chaire autrement c'est ça
tout à fait c'est bien ça vous êtes déjà
conseillère municipale d'opposition
puisque vous aviez fait campagne en 2014
et donc votre deuxième candidature après
celle justement de 2014
alors marine et de torpilles pourquoi
pourquoi y revenir et est ce que vous
estimez que le résultat parce qu'on va
dire le résultat enregistré en 2014
était pas brillant peut-être
encourageant mais parce que luc louison
clémente et avait été élu dès le premier
tour avec plus de 60% des suffrages
exprimés alors estimé vous tout de même
que ce résultat de 2014 est encourageant
et surtout ce qui s'est passé durant
cette mandature
est-ce que c'est encourageant pour vous
pour le scrutin de mars prochain alors
d'abord je voudrais quand même présenter
parce que souvent les des personnes dont
une fausse image de moi je suis donc une
chaîne chinoise mère de quatre enfants
je suis de la campagne de terrain gilles
et j'aime à le dire parce que quand je
passais mes vacances à la campagne chez
ma grand mère on allait manger d icade
dans la savane de nos villages ont passé
chez monsieur et et anouk avait une
boutique
donc tout ça et quand on 74 mes parents
se sont installés à définitivement à
terville
j'ai eu mes voisines qui était
syntonisent victorine ce sont des noms
qui parlent à terville et c'est tout ça
qui m'a construit c'est à dire je suis
tant de la ville ou de la campagne
je suis des deux aspects parce que
souvent vous considérez terville comme
la campagne le oud services et la
campagne est donc et j 7
chez ces deux aspects ces deux aspects
de ma ville c'est et c'est tout ça qui
me construit et c'est tout ça qui fait
ma personnalité et je tenais à le dire
non mais c'est important donc vous
présenter en authentique celle géroises
ans quelle que soit je suis exactement
chez walt de tout de la ville comme de
la campagne et je suis à l'aise partout
je vais à schoelcher alors hormis cela
qu'est ce qui vous a poussé à vous
représenter pour une deuxième fois et
notamment par rapport à ce résultat 2014
qui amélioré par est pas encourageant
oui vous dites vous le dit encourageant
bon ceci dit je pense que
ça fait plus d'un an que je fais du
terrain et je pense que j'ai akaki en
maturité aussi en expérience et échanger
avec les gens j'ai discuté avec eux et
elle a aujourd'hui j'ai vraiment une
vision le cap 2026 que je souhaite pour
shell cher et cette vision nous allons
donc la faire partager
pour proposer donc recherché oiseaux
cherchez pas un programme mais vraiment
une stratégie une stratégie de
développement avec un plan d'action à
faire sur six ans alors on va on va y
venir justement je voudrais juste
rappeler quand même que vous aviez
obtenu quand même 16% des suffrages en
j'avais rappelé le score du du maire qui
avait été réélu mais donc je précise le
vôtre pour le précédent exercice alors
si vous êtes élu marnier de torpilles
qu'elle sera donc en tant que chef de
l'édilité de la municipalité de chelsea
juan votre principale priorité
alors il ya plusieurs priorités d'abord
jeu j'aurai des priorités je dirais
j'aurai des actions symboliques pour
marquer le changement
par exemple des choses toutes bêtes en
mai le fleurissement de nos ronds points
le nettoiement de nous de nos rues
nous avons une pépinière nous pouvons la
mettre en valeur tout le travail que
font des agents de la pépinière
donc pour que quand vous traversez cher
que vous vous rendez compte que vous
êtes effectivement dans une commune
kiryenka beaucoup de dignité
et puis je voudrais mettre des toilettes
sur toutes les places et les plages
aujourd'hui les gens quand ils ont
quelques besoins fait un bon centre de
voitures ce n'est pas possible que ça
soit fait comme ça à schoelcher et puis
il ya d'autres aussi encore une autre
action symbolique c'est que il faut
qu'au niveau de la mairie qu'elle peut
être accessible aux gens à mobilité
réduite
aujourd'hui quelqu'un en fauteuil
roulant ne peut pas assister au conseil
municipal ne peut même pas aller aux
toilettes au niveau de l'état civil
donc il ya vraiment ça ce sont des
actions symboliques des actions de fond
là je serai sûr j'ai tout le programme
sur l'agriculture qui me tient à coeur
et puis aussi sûr parce que nous avons
un terrain qui n'est pas que là on
déconne et nous n'en avons pas beaucoup
mais un vrai programme d'innovation de
création a fait autour de l'agriculture
s'étaient eux seront irrigués et puis
vous avez aussi
sur le numérique je voudrais vraiment
peuvent inscrire cher dans un
développement avec l'outil numérique
sans fracture numérique
les personnes qui ne les personnes d'un
certain âge qui ne sont pas habitués
nous avons des ateliers que je mène déjà
à chuck chercheurs du pas très en retard
de ce point de vue et le travail que ce
n'est pas pour autant que vous avez une
population qui peut être un peu réticent
tout qui peut aussi avoir un peu peur
donc nous serons là pour accompagner les
gens ou bien pour me tenir aussi le haut
les outils traditionnels
en fait tout ça pour dire que nous avons
vraiment un programme alors sur le fond
il ya une chose que je veux dire la
seconde vague de plans fixes qu'on a la
seconde va doter à villé et est à faire
et puis il ya eu les 110 dernièrement
sur la place désarroi wac
ce sera un jardin d'enfants pour moi il
faut aussi un jardin d'enfants pour les
moins de 7 ans et que cette place soit
animé par des appels à projets par par
des commerces et tout prix qu'il faut
que chez cheikh deviennent attractifs et
animé et ben vous me l'apprenez dans la
bouche pour ainsi dire jamais vous
demander qu'est ce qui se joue justement
d'importantes fondamental pour la
population celle ci roises mais pour la
ville elle même
l'une des plus importantes 1 4 ou 5 plus
importante de l'île mais qui a perdu un
petit peu d'animation dans la récession
est en tout cas au moins population et
puis voilà quoi thatcher attire comme il
ya une dizaine mais on est là pour
remettre pour refaire pour remettre du
moteur remettre remettre le moteur en
marche plutôt est une chose aussi qui
est très importante c'est que nous ne
pouvons rien faire si nous n'avons pas
une gestion du personnel qui soit
correct parce que sans le personnel
nous n'y arriverons pas nous voulons un
bloc moteur élus personnel pour répondre
aux besoins de la population
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
marina torpille merci